o gato o gato é muito autossuficiente
ele não precisa de ninguém gato não
precisa de GPS PR nada aí no beard box
quem é cego se salva um quem se
salva é só os gatos que o gato é o MAG
gaiva dos animais o Mister Emo se
inspirou num gato que o primeiro que
teve não era Mister emo era Mister g de
gato Acho que chega o momento da vida do
cachorro que ele já tá puto que ele fica
todo mundo que chega naa casa
fica fazendo vozinha idiota para mim
fica passando a mão em mim eu já tenho
55 anos e ninguém me trata como adulto
eu comparo esses cachorros pequeno e
fofo as mesm pessoa que trabalha vestido
de Dora Aventureira com elho da Paz que
sempre é um velho fumante né que por
fora Ele é fofo PR as crianças mas por
dentro ele é um velho fumante a
menininha diga Butterfly e o cara lá
dentro
Butterfly aí quando dá o intervalo ele
fica atrás do caminhão com a cabeça da
Dora aqui atrás
e